-Rien n'a été simple pour elle,
dans la vie comme en politique,
mais elle a tracé sa route,
franchi les obstacles un à un
pour siéger désormais à l'Assemblée
dans les rangs de la majorité.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Fanta Berete.
-Bonjour.
-S'il y a une chose
qui vous agace en politique,
ce sont les caricatures,
les généralités que certains font,
comme considérer
que tous les députés Renaissance,
dont vous êtes,
sont forcément issus
de milieux favorisés.
On va vous entendre répondre
à vos collègues de LFI,
c'était fin 2022.
-Sur les bancs de la majorité,
nous ne sommes pas
tous issus des classes
que vous décrivez,
ou plutôt que vous haïssez.
Applaudissements
...
Comme vous aimez les prénoms,
moi, je suis la fille de Ibrahima
et Mariam, ouvrier et ouvrière,
retraités, avec une faible pension,
qui a été réévaluée
par cette majorité.
...
J'ai envie de vous dire
que vous ne représentez pas
Ibrahima, Mariam et tous ceux
avec qui j'ai grandi.
Vous êtes une bande
de tiktokeurs qui cherchent le buzz.
-Premier point,
visiblement,
vous n'aimez pas les tiktokeurs.
-Si, j'adore TikTok, en plus.
-Des tiktokeurs.
-J'adore TikTok.
-Comme une insulte.
Ce que vous avez voulu dire,
ce jour-là,
c'est que la gauche
n'a pas le monopole du coeur,
des classes populaires ?
-Ouais, c'est ça, je pense,
moi, j'ai tracé ma route
et je viens
de cette classe et j'estime,
en plus, parce que mes parents
y sont toujours, en fait,
que je les représente,
dans chacun de mes choix,
et je pense que tout
ce que nous faisons en politique,
en fait, c'est pour les Français,
d'une manière générale.
Alors selon les textes,
effectivement,
un angle va être pris, parfois,
sur une catégorie de personnes,
mais la gauche
et surtout la gauche d'aujourd'hui
ne peut pas avoir le monopole
et n'a pas le monopole, en fait.
-Vous évoquez vos parents,
qui sont nés
dans un village en Guinée,
qui sont venus travailler en France,
qui ont été ouvriers,
qui sont aujourd'hui à la retraite.
Vous avez dit qu'ils ont été au RSA,
ils ont connu le RSA.
-Bien sûr.
Nous, on a été élevés
avec le système d'aides sociales,
finalement, parce que mes parents
ont eu des trajectoires compliquées,
on disait à l'époque donc Cotorep,
c'est vrai que ce sont
des travailleurs handicapés
qui ont été exclu du système
et c'est grâce finalement
à ce système que nous connaissons
en France qu'ils ont pu élever
quatre enfants.
-Vous avez eu
une trajectoire assez rare,
exceptionnelle,
qu'est-ce qui l'a rendue possible,
du côté de vos parents,
ils ont dû faire des sacrifices
pour que vous puissiez
faire des études ?
Comment ça s'est passé ?
-Ouais,
je pense que c'était important
pour eux qu'on fasse des études.
J'ai pas été une bonne élève
au démarrage,
puisque je fais partie
de cette génération
qui est allée en lycée professionnel
et qui y est allée pas par choix
mais contrainte et, finalement,
ça m'a amenée à retourner,
finalement,
en lycée, voilà, en lycée général,
et puis ensuite à faire mes études
et à obtenir un bac + 5
et à finir à Sciences Po.
Mais, néanmoins,
depuis que nous étions petits,
mes parents font partie
de ces personnes
qui ont toujours payé
pour des cours supplémentaires,
pour les maths, le français,
qui ont toujours,
ils payaient des cours du soir,
et ma mère faisait un chèque,
en fait, à la fin du mois,
en plus de toutes les charges
qu'elle avait à payer,
y a cette ouverture vers la culture
qui était importante pour eux,
que ce soit au niveau
du sport ou des arts,
on a toujours pu bénéficier
d'un certain nombre d'activités
et ça, je les remercie pour ça.
-Ca représente quoi d'être députée
de la République française,
quand vous vous retournez
sur ce passé ?
-Bah, c'est...
Bah, j'ai toujours les larmes
aux yeux parce que,
en fait,
j'ai envie de vous dire,
je sais pas, c'est toujours
difficile d'en parler,
non mais parce que,
ce sont les gens
qui nous voient comme députés,
c'est-à-dire que, moi,
je reste Fanta Berete,
qui a grandi là où elle a grandi,
mais les gens,
même s'ils sont en colère
contre les hommes et les femmes
politiques, quand vous allez
quelque part en tant que député,
y a ce regard un peu d'admiration,
y a, voilà, ce questionnement,
c'est là que vous vous rendez compte
de ce que vous représentez,
donc effectivement,
y en a 577 tous les cinq ans,
donc en fait,
c'est une expérience incroyable,
mais pour une personne
comme moi,
jamais j'aurais pu
penser un jour m'asseoir,
en fait, donc,
dans cet hémicycle.
-Si on parle un peu politique,
on vous a vue,
sur le projet de loi immigration,
signer cette tribune
transpartisane qui a fait
la une de Libération
dans laquelle vous réclamiez
la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papiers
dans les métiers à tension.
C'est votre histoire familiale
qui parle sur ce sujet
précis ?
-Sur cette tribune,
c'est important
d'arrêter l'hypocrisie.
Que ce soit dans les grandes villes
ou ailleurs,
des personnes nous accompagnent
dans notre quotidien,
font des travaux pour nous,
travaillent dans les cuisines
de nos restaurants,
gardent nos enfants et nos aînés,
et je pense que le temps est venu
qu'on les regarde en face
et qu'on dise qu'ils vont
commencer une vraie vie
car ce sont des vies empêchées,
des gens qui travaillent des heures,
sans reconnaissance du système,
et qui ne peuvent pas s'épanouir
au sein de notre République
comme on voudrait qu'ils le fassent.
-On s'arrête sur votre parcours
d'engagement politique,
vous devenez
d'abord parent d'élève,
puis vous vous présentez
aux municipales
à Paris en 2014
sur une liste citoyenne,
mais le coup d'accélérateur,
ça a été 2016,
le lancement d'En Marche par Macron.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a attirée
dans le projet politique de Macron ?
-Ecoutez,
j'étais déçue du quinquennat
de François Hollande
et je me disais...
-Vous votiez socialiste.
-Ouais, j'avais voté
socialiste, mon père nous demandait
de voter socialiste.
-La consigne de vote familiale.
-Exactement.
Et donc, j'ai été happée
par son discours,
son discours à la télé,
le jour où il présente En Marche,
j'ai mon ordinateur sur les genoux,
je suis dans mon fauteuil rouge
et en fait je l'écoute au journal
et c'est cette notion
de "déplacement",
dépassement
pour chacun d'entre nous.
-Des clivages ?
-Et donc, ouais, effectivement,
qui m'a percutée,
et je trouvais
qu'il avait vraiment envie
de transformer notre société
et donc aussi, voilà,
de vraiment prendre en compte
les enjeux d'aujourd'hui.
-Vous vous êtes engagée en parallèle
de votre carrière professionnelle
dans le domaine
des ressources humaines,
vous êtes référente EM
au 15e arrondissement,
vous en avez fait
la plus grosse structure
militante de Paris à l'époque,
vous pensiez obtenir
l'investiture aux législatives,
ce sera Hugues Renson,
vous serez sa suppléante.
Ca a été une grosse
déception pour vous ?
-Ouais, ça a été dur car j'étais là
au début de l'aventure,
j'ai vu ces étoiles s'aligner,
avec beaucoup de surprise, hein,
parfois, le 10 décembre 2016,
la porte de Versailles,
c'était incroyable.
Et effectivement, je pensais
avoir cette investiture,
l'équipe a choisi Hugues Renson,
qui est devenu vice-président
de l'Assemblée et je pense que,
voilà, l'histoire a montré,
cinq ans après,
que je pouvais y arriver,
mais ça n'a pas été simple.
-Effectivement, on va voir ça,
en détail, cinq ans plus tard,
Hugues Renson ne se représente pas,
mais cette fois,
c'est David Amiel qui a été
choisi à votre place.
Comment vous expliquez que,
à deux reprises,
on ait pas reconnu et récompensé
votre travail sur le terrain ?
Comme si vous étiez
l'éternelle dauphine,
toujours en deuxième position.
-C'est l'histoire de ma vie.
-Je dis dauphine, ou dauphin,
car vous avez dit "un petit dauphin
"au milieu des requins",
comme si vous n'arriviez pas
à vous imposer,
à faire jouer vos réseaux,
ça fait partie de la politique.
-Ouais, moi,
je sais très bien
me battre pour les autres,
alors là, je ne lâche rien,
donc voilà.
Mais c'est toujours plus dur,
finalement,
vous voyez,
si vous êtes manager
dans une entreprise, moi,
j'ai jamais eu de problème à aller
demander pour l'équipe
des rémunérations complémentaires,
mais ça a toujours été
plus compliqué pour moi.
Et je pense que j'ai du mal
à faire passer ce que,
moi, je pouvais apporter
au sein d'une équipe
mais parce que je pense
que j'ai parfois un manque
de confiance en moi qui résonne
par rapport aussi à mon parcours,
et je me dis :
est-ce que c'est moi qui "va" faire
le meilleur job
dans cette position
de première.
-Olivia Grégoire vous prend
comme suppléante
dans la circonscription
juste à côté,
elle était ministre
avant les législatives,
elle l'est redevenue après,
vous faites partie
de ces suppléants devenus
députés quelques semaines
après les autres.
Vous vous êtes regroupés
sur Telegram, pourquoi ?
C'est dur, député suppléant ?
-On est arrivés un mois
après les autres et donc,
c'était la folie.
Et donc, on est tous placés, donc,
sur les rangs du fond et donc...
-Vous êtes les derniers arrivés,
vous prenez les places
qui restent ?
-Mais ce sont de très bonnes places,
je vous assure,
parce que vous avez
une vue sur l'ensemble
de l'hémicycle
et vous ne ratez rien.
-Vous vous êtes donné des conseils ?
-On se donne des conseils
entre nous, on se motive,
y a des heures qui sont parfois
difficiles et, surtout,
y a une solidarité,
c'est important d'avoir l'impression
de faire partie
d'une équipe dans l'équipe.
-Vous êtes de l'aile gauche
de la majorité,
Olivia Grégoire était
assimilée à l'aile droite.
Ca peut créer
des tensions entre vous ?
Comment ça se passe
lors de positions différentes ?
-C'est quasiment jamais arrivé.
Avec Olivia, par exemple,
quand on a su qu'on allait
faire équipe ensemble,
on s'est dit,
je me souviens, un après-midi :
on se parlera
sur le texte fin de vie,
parce que le président a pris
un engagement,
il est possible qu'on ait des idées
qui ne soient pas les mêmes,
et on a une circonscription
qui est très partie prenante,
en fait, sur ce texte-là.
Sur le reste, en toute sincérité,
on s'écrit très souvent,
tous les deux ou trois jours,
sur tout un tas de choses,
mais pas tant sur nos positions.
Sur l'immigration,
je lui ai dit ce que je pensais,
l'important, c'est de la prévenir,
qu'elle sache
aussi se dire :
"je sais que si je suis interrogée",
parce que, pour la peine,
elle fait beaucoup de média,
"je sais quoi répondre".
-Un sujet vous tient très à coeur,
celui des familles
monoparentales,
vous avez vous-même été
mère célibataire
quand vous repreniez
vos études tout en travaillant.
Vous avez fait de ce sujet
un combat politique,
vous pensez pouvoir faire adopter
un dispositif d'aide
d'ici à la fin
de la législature sur ce sujet ?
-Si je reste en place,
il est certain
que je ferai adopter
quelque chose.
-Qu'est-ce qui vous aurait
le plus aidée à l'époque ?
En tant que mère célibataire ?
-Tout ce qui concerne
le système de garde, ça,
c'est le plus dur parce que,
si vous voulez faire carrière,
ça nécessite du temps.
On est encore dans un pays
où on estime qu'à 19h,
si vous êtes là, c'est très bien,
si vous êtes parti à 16h30,
on le voit sur la population
des hommes.
Donc le système de garde,
on peut innover.
-On passe au quiz,
vous devez compléter les phrases
que je vais vous proposer.
Faire de la politique,
c'est renoncer à ?
-Sa vie de famille.
-Oui, c'est dur ?
-Il faut s'organiser,
mais c'est pas évident,
on laisse de côté ses amis,
on commence à ne plus aller
aux dîners, aux anniversaires,
et puis, pour les enfants,
moi, la mienne est grande,
mais ça a un impact.
-Pour mes parents,
avoir une fille
députée ?
-Bah, je pense qu'ils sont fiers,
encore une fois,
ils ont pas pu venir,
c'est un regret.
-A l'Assemblée.
-Mon père a été malade,
il a fait deux AVC,
ma mère est devenue aidante,
et donc, bah j'espère
qu'ils vont pouvoir venir,
ce sera pas évident,
mais je sais qu'ils sont fiers,
mais je crois que je voudrais
voir ça dans leurs yeux
et j'espère vivre ce moment.
-Si Olivia Grégoire quitte
le gouvernement, que ferez-vous ?
-Ecoutez, j'ai la chance
d'avoir pas mal de choses,
donc, pour moi, donc déjà,
je pourrais retourner, donc,
dans mon ancien job,
j'ai un contrat suspendu,
et puis après,
y a plein d'horizons
qui peuvent s'ouvrir,
il faut juste voir les opportunités
et regarder encore
les bonnes étoiles !
-Merci, Fanta Berete,
d'avoir été notre invitée.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...